new images from Russia's defense
Ministry of the continued evacuation of
her son Ukraine calls it a forced
deportation
on Friday for the first time in public
the Russian president added his voice to
the existing orders to leave
those living in Kirsten should be
removed from the zone of the most
dangerous actions because the civilian
population should not suffer from the
shelling from the offensive
counter-offensives or any other actions
connected to the military activities
President Putin was marking Russia's
Unity day but from one of Russia's
civilian administrators in Harrison
there was scad unity in the messaging
first he announced the 24-hour curfew he
said to allow the military to clear the
city of Nazis before deleting the video
and replacing it with this one
in Carson the Fight Continues against
the Insurgency and the Nazi
Collaborators there is no limitation in
Carson that restricts the life of the
city the same official on Thursday
talked to the likely Russian military
withdrawal from the city only to
backtrack on that statement too saying
he hoped it would not happen it all adds
to the intense confusion about the real
situation inside her son
for all the talk of a Russian withdrawal
Ukrainian soldiers north of the city
expect to have to fight for it
the culmination of a counter-offensive
launched in August
we're using such the tactic just to
mislead mislead us make
such a signs that they are living but
they waiting for us to start some
actions but Ukraine's defense minister
is sounding more optimistic about a
Russian Retreat or in his sarcastic
phrasing an act of Goodwill
I think that potentially they are ready
for another Act of Goodwill regarding
the Left Bank of the donipro river just
in the area of the city of her son but
for this they will still have to lose
some of their potential thanks to the
corresponding actions of our armed
forces
in Moscow President Putin accused the
West once again of creating in Ukraine
and anti-russia making conflict with
what he called its Nazis inevitable the
more pressing question now is how the
coming Conflict for her son will play
out Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera Kiev